now part of this video is to obviously
test out nollie I juice but that lies to
prove the safety goggles work or
something yeah yes we're safe to go so
we leave this BB gun what bigger bear in
mind these safety goggles are about
thirty years old so thirty years old
yeah I guess you can go straight for you
name it were will wanna get straight to
it these are old glasses we don't
guarantee for up to thirty one years
ready yep I didn't clap yeah yeah went
in told you it was straight through that
is awful are you ready to get I going on
my guard
okay straight through that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there's one of them get the hose out Oh
funny so that absolutely what admired
flip into here
[Music]
be on the side of the head
[Applause]
so lucky great pure melon did that melon
yeah yeah fine now ahead of time Oh
disgusting after that show I went to
clean the watermelon off the lens and I
was wiping it with a cloth there's a
little oily I was just smearing this
weird oil in the lens and I couldn't get
it clean looking back to the footage
realize that I thought the melon hit the
camera directly in the lens
I was just smearing I juice over the
lens and it would know it that is just
disgusting
if you want to see the full version of
the pig's eye video you can click that
link here right now it's called a high
speed of the bullet in the eye in the
poop in slow-mo it's pretty gross but if
you're into that give that a click this
video is brought to you by audible.com
and if you want to sign up using the
link
audible.com/smarter on your book there's
over 150,000 books to choose from I'm
gonna recommend a clash of kings this
time because I finished Game of Thrones
and I've moved on next book please also
after you've done that you should
subscribe to the slow mo guys channel
and after that you should probably do
something more productive but this I
imagine you filmed internet for quite
some time
you
[Music]